कि नमस्कार जयंती के हिंदी में कि नेक्स्ट
एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज हम सीखने
वाले हैं कंसेप्ट if you like this one यह
बहुत ही इंपोर्टेंट कंसेप्ट है और यह ऐसे
कंसेप्ट कि जिससे लोग बहुत डरते हैं मैंने
बी1 बी2 तो छोड़ो सी1 और सी2 सीखने वाले
लोगों को विच कंसिस्ट्स है डरते हुए देखा
है अपन डोंट वरी हम इसको जितना इजी कर
सकते हैं उतना कम करने की कोशिश करेंगे और
उसके लिए दो चीज हैं पहली चीज तो इसके लिए
आपको बहुत ज्यादा प्रैक्टिस लगेगी यू हैव
टू व्हो प्रैक्टिस पर दिस कंसेप्ट और
दूसरी चीज यह हम 2 पार्ट्स में सीखने वाले
हैं पहले आप जॉब पार्ट सीखने वाले उसकी आप
बहुत ज्यादा प्रैक्टिस करना और फिर सात
दिन के बाद जब हम नेक्स्ट पार्ट सीखेंगे
तब उसके साथ जा सकते हो ठीक है तो सबसे
पहले हम समझ लेते हैं कि वह यह कंसेप्ट है
क्या रे क्यों देख लेना चिकन है क्या तो
यह कम से कम हमारी यह नहीं नहीं है
दोस्तों वह जैसे हमने जो इंग्लिश में जब
पहले देखा था कि हिंदी में जो
मेरा बेटा मेरी बेटी मेरे बच्चे मेरा मेरी
मेरे होता है वह इंग्लिश में तो यह क्या
होता है माय माय माय पर जब मन में उसका
माइनर - माइ नेम होता था या दें कि दर्द
या सुख समृद्धि टेबल है वैसे अगर आप
देखोगे तो इंग्लिश में हिंदी में जो अच्छा
बच्चा अच्छे अच्छे अच्छे अच्छे अच्छे
अच्छे अच्छे से आपने जो एडजेक्टिव है उसको
चेंज नोक की तरह इंग्लिश में नहीं हिंदी
में तो अच्छा अच्छे-अच्छे होता है जर्मन
में भी वैसे ही होता है तो जैसे था वैसे
जो भी होगा यहां तक कि अनफॉर्चूनेटली और
थोड़ा सा जाता है कि जर्मन में ना कि अगर
3 व्यक्तियों के लिए तीन टेबल फैन
कि मैं उन्हें बप्पा टाइट दिखाता हूं पहला
टाइप है डेफिनिटी बल्कि साथ मतलब अगर आप
देर दीदार यादव के साथ अगर हो तो
Tubelight का मीटर रीडर अलग होगा फिर अगर
अप इंटर्टि्वंड आर्टिकल के साथ हो मतलब
त्यौहार है उसके साथ हो क्लॉक का गुड
स्कूटर का टेबल होगा और अगर आपका कोई भी
आर्टिकल नहीं है तो अपना डायरेक्टिव बोल
रहे हो तो वोटर कार्ड एवं होगा मुझे पता
है थोड़ा सा कन्फ्यूजिंग है इसीलिए आप
इसको स्टेप बाय स्टेप ठीक है ओके तो तीन
टाइप के टेबल हो सकते हैं यह रोटी के लिए
ओके तो आज हम क्या करेंगे जो थर्ड टेबल है
कि दौड़ेंगे आर्टिकल वह आज हम सीखेंगे ओके
और वह हमारा पक्का हो जाएगा तब हम पहले दो
टेबल को देखने जाएंगे सिंपल है तो पहला
मतलब क्या कि डायरेक्ट डिस्चार्ज रेड बॉल
या फिर आई है वह डोंट नादर बोलता और को
पिंपल आई है वह बोल आई क्लीवलैंड कॉल संजय
दत्त जब उसके साथ कोई भी आर्टिकल नहीं है
यह हमारी पहली केस टेक्निकल यह थर्ड के से
हम उसको पहनने करके सीखने वाले क्योंकि
तरफ देखोगे तो वह बहुत सिंपल है तो उसके
लिए जो पेपर है वह भी आप स्क्रीन पर दिख
रहा होगा अगर आप देखोगे शांति से तो इस अ
वेरी वेरी सिमिलर टेबल टू आवर डेयर दीदार
ड्यूटेबल अगर आपको देखोगे मेरे साथ बोलो
एग्स पेटीएम एग्जाम मिनट में थोड़ा सा
फर्क है एन पर प्रेस मीट आफ थे नेटिव एंड
ए नेटिव इन यूज नहीं करोगे माय बुक नज़रे
ऐसे नहीं बोलोगे फिर सेकंड वीडियो के एंड
में हम एक सेंटेंस मैं आपको बताता हूं कि
इन थे कंडीशन आफ के राइट नऊ
नीतू कैंसिल रिपोर्ट की नीतियों को सिर्फ
नॉमिनेटिव को अट्रैक्टिव में रहना है ओके
तो अगर आप वो टेबल देखो कि अगर अफसर तो
आपको मंत्र याद होगा दर्द कर देंगे और अगर
यह टेबल देखोगे कि ऐसी यह नहीं ऐसी हमारे
में एकदम सेम है राइट और देखने का तरीका
भी एक्जेक्टली सेम है वह हमने वहां पर
कैसे किया था ख अगर आए हैं उज्जवल जॉब
वंडरलैंड किया था और उसके इसे क्या बोला
था कि वह बॉल खुद मेल है और इस सेंटेंस
में पॉजिटिव इसलिए जाकर देखा था यहां पर
वैसे ही करना है हम सारे टाइप के
सेंटेंसेस देखते हैं तो आपको थोड़ा सा
कॉन्फिडेंस आ जाएगा ठीक है तो पहले हमारा
इदं बेसिक सेंटेंस लेते हैं जिससे इस रेड
रोजेस र रेड कॉल रेट इन इंडिया अंडर लाइन
करो बोल क्या है मेल और यह सेंटेंस का यह
मैं बोल क्या है सब्जेक्ट है नॉमिनेटेड कि
जिस सिर्फ पोर्ट्रेट नॉमिनेटिव मेल क्या
है देखो लैंडिंग कि यार
तोता सिस्टम router बौद्ध स्ट्रॉल एकदम
सिंपल मैसेज करते हैं दूसरे रेडो वॉच पेड़
के नीचे करो वॉच क्या है वह फीमेल खुद तुम
हो नॉमिनेटिव सेंटेंस में क्या है कि दास
इस्ट रूट पर और वैसे ही अगर आपको करना है
तो दूसरे रेड का किसी फ्रेंड का रखे थे के
बीच सेंटर लाइन नॉमिनेटिव और न्यूट्रल
कार्स उपलब्ध तो क्या ऊपर रोटेट थम टो रूल
थे सिटी में देखते हैं रेड आई हैव रीड ऑल
सब्जेक्ट कौन है मेरे पास है तो सेंड करो
कि क्या होगा आपको ट्यूब मेल इस हावड़ा
रूट इन बाल प्रोटीन वाले बटन पर मैसेज
सेंड करो कि इस हब्बल रोट व इस चावल रोटी
सिमिलरली आईएफ रेड का फिर से रिमाइंडर करो
इन क्वांटम होने के बाद क्या होगा कि देखो
न्यूट्रल इस हावड़ा रूट टो रोट ए वेरी
सिंपल अगर आपको में करना है तो कैसे करोगे
हम इसमें प्ले विद बॉब आगे मतलब क्या होता
है इसलिए इसकी रूट एंबा सिंपल
एक मैसेज अगर आपको करना है हाय प्ले विद
रेड वॉच इन वंडरलैंड आरटीओ फीमेल स्पीड
लिमिट रोटर वैसे ही आई प्ले विद रेड कार
डुबो न्यूटन स्पीड लिमिट रोटेट थम ओंटो
सिंपल अगर यह आपको समझ में आई है तो आपको
पता है कि को या फिर जब विशेषण आता है तो
आपको समझ कर लेते हैं तो मुझे फिर से मैं
हूं subscribe our Channel कि आप क्या
बोलोगे आपको इस रूट को एकदम सिंपल वे
ए बेसिक हम यहां पर क्या देखे हैं कि बाबा
जैसे तुम इंग्लिश जैसे तुम कैसे इसमें कर
रहे थे वैसे ही हम ने किया वह जो खुद रोड
है उसको रोटरडम रोटन जो भी लगने वाला था
वह डिपेंडिंग अपऑन अपना टेबल लगने वाला था
तो यह आपको अभी विदाउट आर्टिकल वाला टेबल
समझ में आया तो अभी आपको क्या करना है याद
रखो जैसे मैंने बोला कि नेटो का टेंशन
लेने की कोई जरूरत नहीं है वह यूज नहीं
करने वाले आप भी आपको नेक्स्ट 7 दिन तक
क्योंकि हमारा जो नेक्स्ट इसका जो पार्ट
है वह मिक्स संडे लेने वाला होगी बुद्धवार
को मैं लाइव आने वाला हूं और नेक्स्ट 7
दिनों तक आपको क्या होने वाला है अभी हर
रोज आप कम से कम 5 सेंटेंसेस कम से कम 5
सेंटेंसेस के बनाते जाओ तो यह आपको
कॉन्फिडेंस आ जाएगा और जब आप नेक्स्ट संडे
को जब आप या फिर से वीडियो देखोगे तब अपने
अट लीस्ट 40 से 50 सेंटेंस अपने बनाए
होंगे तो आपकी यह एडिक्टिव गेम अच्छे गेम
विदाउट
तक टीजर होनी चाहिए स्पीड लिमिट रोट ए नोट
टो या आना चाहिए यह आपका जब परफेक्ट होगा
तो बाकी के तो टेबल स्पेशल देखने है ना वह
बहुत सिंपल है वह हम आराम से नेक्स्ट
क्लास में देख लेंगे कोई टेंशन नहीं है
सबको बर्ड इंपोर्टेंट क्या है कि देखो आई
माइसेल्फ हैव मेड ए मिस्टेक विद माय और
ईयर बेसिस मैंने अपने टेस्ट कैरियर पहले
बिछा केमिस्ट्री कि तिब्बतियों टेबल एक ही
दिन दे दो अननोन पीपल गेट कन्फ्यूज्ड और
एक डर बैठ जाता है कि आज एक्टिव इन दोनों
के बीच में इसीलिए आज की घंटे तक हम सिंपल
सी रहे हैं प्लस से मैश देर द करेक्ट आज
के दिन जब मैं कुछ अलग नहीं था इस वजह से
दायर किया था वैसे होटल की है कुछ बड़ी
बात नहीं है तो उसका कॉन्फ्रेंस लोग पहले
यह बनाना सीखो उसके बाद बाकी के दो टेबल
हमने इस क्लास में देखने वाले
मैं कोई बड़ी बात यह अगर आपके लायक नहीं
देख रहे हो बहुत दिनों बाद अगर आप यह
वीडियो देख रहा तभी मैं आपको इनक्रीस कर
लूंगा इमिजेटली बाद का वीडियो मत देखना
पहले यह वीडियो देखने के बाद सात दिन तक
प्रैक्टिस करो जब आपका यह टेबल परफेक्ट हो
जाए तभी नेक्स्ट ड्यूटेबल को जाना है ए चल
थोड़ा सा रिवाइज करते हैं वह सबसे पहले
आपने क्या बोला कि पहली डेट में इसका मतलब
क्या कि वह अट्रैक्टिव को चलाना है जैसे
हम हिंदी में करते थे अच्छा लड़का अच्छी
लड़की वैसे कोई नई बात नहीं है
अनफॉर्चूनेटली क्या है दौर की दादी का यह
की टेबल था इसके तीन टेबल होते हैं अगर आप
एडिट आर्टिकल के साथ हो तो इन थे आर्टिकल
के साथ हो तो और विदाउट आर्टिकल को तो फिर
आज आपने क्या सीखा हमने विदाउट आर्टिकल
वाला टेबल सीधा क्योंकि वह बहुत सिंपल था
हमने दर्द ही ऐसा था जो मेरे साथ शेयर पीठ
एम एस पीठ ऐमेज़ॉन जैसे मैंने बोला
रिलेटिव का टेंशन लेने की जरूरत नहीं है
और
कि हमने जैसे हमने केसेस में किया था कि
वह सेंटेंस लांडरिंग करो आपको लड्डू मेल
देखो वैसे ही हमने यहां पर भी किया और फिर
हमने बनाया किरदार सिस्टम वोटर बाल इछावर
रोटन बाल स्पीड लिमिट प्रोटेम बल मुझे आशा
है कि आपको यह कंसेप्ट ठीक से समझ आई होगी
प्लीज इसे डिवाइस कीजिए क्योंकि इसमें
सबसे इंपोर्टेंट है कि वह इसकी प्रैक्टिस
करना प्लीज की प्रैक्टिस करते रहिए है वह
हम जैसे मैंने बोला हम इस बुधवार को मिलने
वाले हैं अलाइव में और नेक्स्ट संडे को हम
इसका सेकंड पार्ट लेंगे बाकी के दो टेबल
हम मिलते हैं बुधवार को लाइव में धन्यवाद